guinea guinea baisao papua new guinea
and of course equatorial guinea since
you have ears you'll notice that they
all share a common name something which
few other countries do since even states
with similar names get mixed up but why
is this the case why are there so many
countries with guinea in their name so
before we answer that there's something
that needs to be cleared up the guineas
and the guyanas are not related two
different words with two different
histories the one we're focusing on most
likely comes from an old berber word
which means dark skin and it was used to
describe the collective lands along the
coast of their south and the people who
lived there europeans only had a few
names for parts of africa like barbary
for the north ethiopia for most of the
continent another term for this area and
guinea was adopted for these lands you
see europeans made use of north african
navigators to help them sell down the
coast of africa and so it wasn't long
until the name for the region stuck with
all of them and when europeans later
colonised the area the different
european powers used guinea to refer to
their separate parts of it the first was
portugal who claimed this area calling
it portuguese guinea there was also
swedish guinea which would later become
danish guinea and soon after that dutch
guinea before the british took it for
themselves and called it the gold coast
in the late 19th century france had its
turn to colonize parts of the area and
in a shocking display of originality
called it french guinea later when de
colonization saw africa freed french
guinea was the first to win its
independence and so it got dibs on plain
old guinea about 20 years later
portuguese guinea followed and it soon
took the name guinea by sao to the south
mostly outside of the region is
equatorial guinea this was first
colonized by portugal who soon sold this
island to the spanish who soon took
control of this region in the late 19th
century the french muscled in on this
region they signed a deal with the
spanish which settled on these borders
with spain gaining the small colony of
rio muni which combined with the island
of biaco in 1929 and it called this
combination spanish guinea because the
island of biako was a part of the region
despite the rest not being so and when
the nation gained its independence it
kept the name guinea but given that
guinea was already taken it adopted the
name equatorial guinea because of its
location so what about papua new guinea
on the other side of the world which is
firmly and entirely not within the
region of guinea well before europeans
arrived the island was known as papua
but cultural sensitivity is not the
cornerstone of imperialism and said the
spanish explorers who first mapped the
island's coastline picked a new name new
guinea so why guinea and not something
else like new aragon well they chose
this name because as far as they were
concerned the natives who lived on papua
were indistinguishable from the africans
of guinea and so they were essentially
the same several centuries later the
island was divided between three powers
with the netherlands germany and britain
taking their own chunks as you know
germany's team came second in world war
one and so their part went to britain
and in 1949 both parts were united under
australian leadership in 1975 it gained
its independence and given that the name
had been used for about four centuries
at this point it just sort of stuck and
that's why there are four countries
called guinea i hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
a special thanks to my patrons james
bisonette kelly money maker mr wolf sky
chappelle corso wolff jerry lambda in
adam stalter jordan longley rod d martin
wyan hockey spencer lightfoot captain
cydog marvin cassell gustav swan buggily
wiggly words about books podcast robert
wetzel winston k wood aaron the white
matthew shipley alex schwinn maggie
paxkowski corey turner anthony beckett
copper tone the mukwopa spinning three
plates charles the first ben evinson and
scottish trekkie